[Musique]
voici le petit train bleu qui veut
révolutionner le transport ferroviaire
grâce à l'hydrogène en essais en
allemagne terminus sigma ring naissant
célèbre château un trajet d'une heure 20
minutes depuis echinghen 50 km plus au
nord avec une vingtaine de stations sur
ce genre de petites lignes régionales
l'électrification serait bien trop cher
pour l'instant le diesel est ce qu'il y
a de plus économique mais il a ses
inconvénients
depuis le mois de juin le train bleu
remplace quatre fois par jour les trains
jaunes qui eux fonctionnent au diesel
ce train bleu est un prototype prêté par
le constructeur alstom pour des clients
potentiels ici la speg compagnie
ferroviaire qui appartient au land de
bade-würtemberg
les train bleu et jaune sont identiques
ce sont des corps alia sauf que le bleu
baptisée high link fonctionne avec des
piles à combustible à hydrogène zéro
émission si ce n'est un peu de vapeur
d'eau manuel schweitzer fait partie du
club fermé des tout premiers conducteurs
du premier train à hydrogène du monde
avec son collègue conducteurs de trains
diesel ils discutent des différences le
train bleu kit sigma riggen pour la
deuxième fois il roule surtout en fin
d'après-midi les différences avec le
train diesel sont frappants
des très silencieux c'est comme un
tramway dans une grande ville est
agréable à conduire c'est formidable par
rapport au diesel les émissions sont
plus écologiques ces mots pour la nature
et c'est plus agréable pour les
passagers parce qu'on n'y a pas de bruit
depuis le mois de juin les passagers
apprécient nettement ses différences
c'est beaucoup mieux que les autres
trains parce qu'ils sont bruyants et il
put celui-ci sambron il est agréable ce
jeune homme le prends cinq à six fois
par semaine pour le travail
j'aime bien prendre ce train parce
qu'ils protègent l'environnement et les
plus silencieux que le train normal et
c'est beaucoup plus agréable pour les
gens qui vivent le long de la voie
ferrée et pour moi aussi
cette britannique vit et étudie en
allemagne
je prends l'autobus être à chaque jour
et si je peux j'en profite pour réduire
mon empreinte écologique
[Musique]
le train bleu a été conçu à salses
khiter en basse saxe par alstom cette
usine construit les trains coradia qui
roule partout en europe mais c'est train
jaune au diesel devrait être remplacé
dans douze ou quinze ans par les bleus
les coralia lint monté sur une ligne
parallèle ceux ci sont les 14 premiers à
être livrées sous peu au système
ferroviaire du land de basse saxe
[Musique]
l'armé secrète du train bleu et
canadiennes c'est la pile à combustible
conçue par hydrogen x de mississauga en
ontario qui vient d'être acquise par
comments le géant américain des moteurs
qui entame son virage écologique le high
link est plus cher qu'un train diesel
mais ce le sera de moins en moins
[Musique]
les trains coûte un peu plus cher mais
il faut penser à l'ensemble du modèle
l'investissement et les coûts
d'opération ceux d'un train à hydrogène
la maintenance et l'approvisionnement
énergétique sont déjà moins cher que les
coûts d'opération d'un diesel sans
compter la hausse actuelle du prix du
carburant
alstom possède pour l'instant la seule
station de recharge en hydrogène le
plein se faire vingt minutes comme pour
le diesel autonomie et 2000 km avec un
plein et une vitesse maximale de 140 km
heure comme le diesel également mais
avec pollution zéro
[Musique]
la pile à combustible à hydrogène
produit une réaction chimique avec
l'oxygène de l'air ambiant pour générer
l'électricité qui propulse le train un
bémol cependant ce n'est pas de
l'hydrogène vert produit par une énergie
renouvelable éolienne par exemple
hydrogène provient de sources
différentes c'est un mélange d'hydrogène
verts et de sous produits de l'industrie
mais nous projetons d'avoir bientôt une
majorité d'hydrogène vers ce sous
produit à l'hydrogène gris comme celui
de l' usine voisine salzgitter ag l'une
des plus gros aciéries du monde qui
brûlera encore 2 millions de tonnes et
demie de charbon par an jusqu'en 2050
ceci dit le petit train bleu fait son
chemin il a circulé en autriche et en
france il y à 27 commandes fermes pour
francfort et une douzaine de trains
régionaux hybride électricité et
hydrogène en france beaucoup d'intérêt
dans plusieurs pays d'europe et
l'amérique du nord
canada et l'amérique du nord sont des
marchés intéressants peu de lignes sont
électrifiés et il ya une demande pour
des émissions zéro l'hydrogène est donc
une bonne solution il y à des expertises
dans les piles à combustible au canada
et en amérique du nord et aussi des
développements technologiques très
intéressant la technologie est prête
elle peut être appliquée à toute sorte
de train pas seulement à des petits
trains régionaux comme celui du sud de
l'allemagne c'est génial je pense que
cette unité a très bien pour la future
ce n'est pas le petit train bleu qui
sauvera la planète mais il indique une
des bonnes voies à suivre
[Musique]